all right i'm laura ingram this is
ingram angle from washington tonight
thanks for being with us
kamala skips to 2024 that is the focus
of tonight's angle
now frantically trying to shake off his
lame duck status jill biden's busy
rallying support in the senate
a headline in the hill tells the story
democratic senators say biden
not too old for a second term
senators are trying to sound
enthusiastic about the soon-to-be
octogenarian now one of biden's closest
allies on the hill chris coons said i
look forward to working hard for joe
biden in 2024 come on and bob casey
predicted he's going to be the nominee
and he's going to be strong
but they know what we know come on there
is no jomentum out there
and as the whiff of political rigor
mortis hovers over biden attention is
already turning to the field of
potential 2024 contenders
now first up kamala harris
now if you're doing the pros and cons
the only real pro i can think of is that
she knows her way around the west wing
like where all the bathrooms are and
stuff other than that
she's been a total bomb
they made her the de facto border chief
remember that and what does she have to
show for it
since biden took office more than 3
million people have been encountered or
apprehended entering the united states
illegally from over 150 countries
now the vice president of course avoids
the border subject altogether refusing
to address the huge uptick in the
illegal border crossers and the number
just over the last six months now the
numbers by the way are not slowing down
in the first five months of this year
alone more than a million people have
been encountered or apprehended entering
the country illegally
they total more than the individual
populations of delaware south dakota
north dakota alaska the district of
columbia vermont and wyoming
well
at this point
how is this called anything but an
ongoing invasion of the united states
historic numbers here
239
416
illegal crossings that is now the
highest number in dhs history there were
100
699 title 42 expulsions representing
only about 42 percent of the total and
there were a staggering 14
699 unaccompanied children that's up 21
over april kamala harris said about a
year ago that extreme progress was being
made at the border she's honestly
useless
i don't know why she's in that position
she hasn't been here in south texas to
see what their policies are creating the
mess
that they're they're creating in our
country
and that their policies are hurting real
people
now our president and vice president and
the incompetent radical they put in at
dhs they're all responsible for this
now in a sane world
this subversion of our sovereignty would
be an impeachable offense but in kamala
land it's grounds for a promotion in
2024
and we haven't even touched on her
extensive gaffes
we have to have the ability
to address the root causes
of why people leave root causes are
based on the problems and the challenges
that people are facing diplomatic tests
turn political quicksand her allies in
the white house and elsewhere are
watching it and just kind of wondering
what is going on we've been to the
border you haven't been to the border
and i haven't been to europe
and i mean we're told that some of what
she said on the trip for answers to
questions maybe even obvious questions
those answers have white house insiders
perplexed i am here
standing here on the northern flank on
the eastern flank talking about what we
have in terms of the eastern flank and
our nato allies vice president kamala
harris on a visit to poland came under
some criticism okay
a friend in need is a friend
and now perhaps in an attempt to expand
her impressive resume of failure kamala
harris is taking on yet another role one
that will do nothing to help the average
american
but will burnish her left-wing bona
fides
i give you kamala harris information and
surveillance czar
we continue to see
how some acts of mass violence have
followed expressions of online hate and
abuse this task force then
will tackle a threat
that has been far too real for far too
many people for far too long it will
lead to more evidence-informed policies
and interventions
my god is anyone more annoying than her
delivery there now the white house had
time for this big rollout today of this
new task force on it's on online
harassment and abuse which you may be
kind of quick to dismiss as just a
warmed over dhs disinformation board
remember that kind of got disbanded um
but that's not what's really going on
here kamala comes with big guns
including the national security council
the white house gender policy council
the surgeon general and even the doj is
promising to get involved
the department of justice is eager to
take place
to take its role
take part in the critical work of this
task force we will publish an annual
report
on this information
and all the information that we gather
to further inform our enforcement
efforts
now this will include efforts to police
language to effectively insulate
political figures and journalists from
disinformation abuse and harassment
so
biden's doj refuses to investigate
actual abuse and harassment of pro-life
pregnancy centers all across the country
which is clear domestic terrorism but
they're pledging money and manpower to
criminalize the expression
of speech of their political opponents
and i have to ask this tonight you heard
merrick garland there what actually
constitutes abuse and harassment who
makes that call
now to these people refusing to use
i don't know someone's preferred gender
pronouns
that would constitute a hate crime
again but actual acts of violence
against their political opponents are
downplayed or they're just ignored
altogether
today's epidemic of hate which is
fueling violent acts
against many communities
this
is also american history
and we must teach it
as it really happened
we can fight ignorance
dispel misinformation
and work toward a future where all
people
can live without fear
live without fear what kind of utopia is
she living in again who gets to
determine what is and what is not
misinformation that is not the
government's role
the first amendment isn't absolute you
can't scream fire in a crowded theater
but it sure as heck protects political
speech absolutely
hate only cuts one way in kamala town
so without fail if the choices between
protecting our freedom
and catering to anti-american fanatics
in her own party kamala will always
choose the latter
but lucky for us the best way to ensure
the failure of any task force
is to put her at its health
from her embarrassing on-camera
performances to her glaring lack of
intellect
kamala would be a very very risky bet
for the dems post biden
so no wonder
so many in her party are already looking
for an off-ramp
to get another gadfly pete bootaj in
center stage
after all both would be first would they
end up cancelling each other out you got
to wonder and if so
wait if they canceled each other out
would that mean what i think it would
mean
my name is joe biden i'm jill biden's
husband
yeah
and america's undoing and that's the
angle hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else